your necklace looks really pity on you
thank you no problem
she's totally straight
oh no she could told me be gay those
nails that's what aren't you straight
but she this'll be game for the record
I'm straight how do you meet anyone any
more straight girls go to gay bars be
dating is weird are you okay I'm sorry I
just I just got a really long term
yesterday like really fresh online
dating is a bust
I love adventure and me and my boyfriend
are looking for an adventurous girl to
join us I've never been with a woman
before
hi I'm in an open marriage and we're
looking for another woman
sorry I I'm Amy so my
you ever just need someone then feel
someone that you feel like you know
everything about just by looking into
their eyes
I know we only met two hours ago but I
really think with what I meant to be
with
sorry it's my boyfriend's your what
actually we're looking for a fun girl
for a threesome would you pop that
pyramid so is that a No
he could just watch
hi hey guys up here we made a series
it's coming on November 18th please
watch it get it here yeah yeah over
there you gotta see it it'll be released
2015 November okay